لطالما كان cutter مفتوحًا للأعمال التجارية
ليس فقط لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي ولكن أيضًا على مستوى العالم
أعتقد أن هذا الحصار والتحديات
التي حدثت في دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
ستكون على الأرجح فرصًا أكثر
لدولة قطر معظم ما فعلناه
سابقًا كان كثيرًا  فيما يتعلق بالتكامل بين دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
اليوم ، أعتقد أننا
نركز كثيرًا أيضًا على
كيفية استدامة الذات والاعتماد
على الذات على العديد من قطاعات الاقتصاد ، لذلك
أعتقد أن المضي قدمًا لا أعتقد أن
الاقتصاد القطري أو سياسته الاقتصادية
ستتغير  في الواقع ، سيكون الأمر أكثر
مرونة نحن اليوم في الشهر الثامن
من الحصار ، ويمنحنا الكثير من
الناس بضعة أسابيع للنجاة من هذا
على الرغم من كل ما كان لدينا في الشهر الثامن ،
ما زلنا الأسرع ، هذا
نزاع قبلي لأنه من الخارج
يبحث في  يبدو أن قائدين شابين في
المملكة العربية السعودية وقطر
لا يجدان أرضية مشتركة وعليك
تسمية الحياة بهذه الطريقة ، سيكون هذا في
الواقع الوضع الطبيعي الجديد مع قطر وليست
جزءًا من الخليج.  تعتقد
أنك تعلم أننا نتوقع أحيانًا
خلافات سياسية بطريقة أو بأخرى ، أعتقد أن
التحدي المتمثل في ذلك كان حقًا
النسيج الاجتماعي لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي ، الأشخاص ،
والأسر والأطفال الذين تعرفهم ، الناس
تعرف أن أسرهم تمزق
بعضًا منهم كما تعلم  لديهم عائلات
في المملكة العربية
السعودية تبدو شخصية للغاية وهذا
ما أقول دائمًا أنه
تجاوز الخلاف السياسي العادي